good evening everybody
and any projects Robson's Oh pilchard
Dre and council Mason rather not members
attending and before we actually start
meeting can I introduce you to the
external auditors by very private side
it's a nice meet you and Joseph who is
now head of finance and Jim who's the
auditor okay sorry I just most people
knew they were sorry but didn't mean to
they know half my right minutes amazing
held intensive arch happy yes these are
too too wrinkled receive any decorations
of interest
no questions on notice motions on notice
in right so we'll start with item 7 and
our students go through that one excuse
me I keep losing my voice for some
reason chairman I could certainly see an
update on the external auditor reports
when the external auditors or other
groups make recommendations we monitored
to ensure there are implemented or
carried forward and took two were
implemented on paper 7.3 and 7.4 is the
runs that were outstanding as at the
last time I'd like to bring members
attention to the second last one that
was due to be revised to the 31st of my
this has now been invented by the rivers
of benefits section so all the
outstanding recommendations have now
been implemented any questions
the recommendation it is proposed that
the committee results from hoping clip
from video recommendations arising from
the annual governance report 2013-14
fifth grade grade and to that the
monitoring even video recommendations
arising from the grants claims and
return certificate certificate
certificate thank you report 2013-14
beer breeding rights and eight of pants
I Bou to bury amazing
so beginning 8.4 and is just out in good
plans throughout with here and invested
March 15 and awards I chemistry the
executive summary which is on 826 that
just highlights the key areas and in
particular just draw attention to the
significant risks that we've identified
as a result of our plan and so it's into
the financial statements you'll see
there are two significant risks there
the first one management override is
actually prescribed by by auditing
standards so it's a risk that would
appear at any organization that we were
to audit and it just reflects the fact
that the position that management hold
means that they're able should they wish
to to override any controls that the
council may have in the place and as I
say that is a standard significant risk
so it's one that we have to address and
as you see in the narrative there we'll
do that by looking at various things
including the appropriate miss of
accounting estimates will look at
journals of
but through the general ledger have an
impact on the accounts and just make
sure we're happy with all the folks the
second risk there in relation to the
financial statements is in relation to
revenue recognition now again auditing
standards presume that this risk exists
as it says they may arise for various
factors application of inappropriate
accounting policies and failure to apply
state of accounting policies and so on
now getting fat it's presumed means that
we need to consider it what we will do
is we will revisit that particular risk
the revenue recognition risk once we've
received the draft financial statements
because it will be dependent on the
amount of revenue that's been recognized
in that income as being recognized and
what the nature of that income is so
then have a look at that and determine
how exams approach moving on to the use
of resources and the value of money work
and
on this first assessment you may or may
not be aware that we have an issue
recently with South in chief financial
officer this shoveling away for your
thousand pounds over a number of years
is this in which should you pick this up
from your your first section here where
it says management / life because it was
obviously something going on it's out
there that you could do it over a number
of years and then is there is there any
way that you can eat this Apple or this
is where this would happen we yeah I
mean management I wasn't having fun no
I'm not just a heads of averages big
wide profile thing yeah I mean it that
is an example of management override so
he owes of an individual's position they
were able to do that i won with
necessary if it up and spotted it now
obviously we will when we do our work we
examples that we pick those at random
and so if we were to pick a particular
item that happen to fall within that set
of transactions that were inappropriate
and then yes we would it will also
depend on the amounts as well so we
apply a level of materiality which is
talked about later on
in our audience a guide to help us
determine what balances in the accounts
that we look at obviously we can't look
at every single transaction that's gone
through in here so we have to have a
threshold which we use to determine
exactly what we'll look at now about
40,000 pounds is unlikely to be above
optic of threshold and i think if you
look later on the report we've set
initially about 700,000 pounds at work i
gay there is no way that you could or
you would we say frog the same target
management of all people in positions
that could do this you don't do a rather
your specific it at areas blue
no other than looking at things like
journals which obviously management
codes yeah complete and post so we will
look at those who would anything unusual
there so that kind of here focus work
does happen and I could potentially bit
something
thinking and yes I such as moving on to
the the financial resilience risk there
finally this is in relation to our money
work and that just recognizes the fact
that account source it has to make
savings over the medium term so looking
in the next five years and softly go
through a restructure internally and and
all of those fats just come together and
again rochford isn't alone in that risk
of see most councils are facing
significant financial pressure and
medium too and so that that risk exists
and what do so focused work on that just
to look at are you put together in the
medium term financial plan and the
impact of the restructuring is it
realizing the savings that that the
council intended it would so that would
be a focus of that work
cash out because and they make me a cat
can we take each city on space with an
8.7 I'd like to bring up a point which
we've just been discussing
we feel that I feel an ugly need to do
as well that we're very understaffed now
with orbitals with 11 part time and part
time there's opportunity what is your
thought on on the number of people we've
got world it to be we've got enough to
cover and well I think I suppose time
will tell I mean I know that the unit
plan is a theme park this agenda in
terms of monitoring now know that the
internal enters will agree to human
committee to progress against that
reform and I played them from the
outcome of that and in terms of the the
coverage again I think that week for the
committee to take a view on whether they
think that the intern with plan provides
appropriate coverage it probably
wouldn't terms of 1516 necessarily be
appropriate for me to comment at this
stage I think it does fall kind of
within the remit of all I was just
talking about in terms of the
restructure so as well as thinking about
whether or not it's delivered the
savings so the financial aspect of that
restructuring there is also the delivery
aspect i suppose and i think that's
something we will have a look at and
primarily in terms of
determining how the council have
considered the impact on delivery but in
terms of external delivery so to service
users also internal which which would be
the case with internally in terms of the
intern
and
I don't know internal bit of a comment
on that but that that would be in terms
of our approach to thinking about that
that's something we will consider
probably a high level initially we have
concerns we may look at it in a bit more
detail in terms of how the council any
contingencies in place to address any
potential shortfall which made act on
these shores you can take the work
internally okay maybe more discusses
later on as it comes up under the turtle
she okay 8.8 in 15 min late complain is
played by 98 more tender yes actually I
wouldn't have stayed in your timetable
and looking at these assumptions and the
and so that will fall within the final
audit visit which will start to lose in
July and run through August we will I'm
also aware that that medium term
financial strategy obviously one was
published in July's part of the budget
setting for 1516 that will be updated as
has been the case in previous years
following closure of the 14 15 counts
and we there were also be further
announcements from the Chancellor are
suspecting yeah like which may or may
not impact on that medium term financial
strategy so ideally I'd like to look at
it after those things have happened
because it will be able to date version
in terms of reporting back to the
committee and our our conclusion and
value-for-money conclusion which is what
that work falls under and we have to
report back to you by the thirtieth of
September so effectively the next
committee will issue a final report
which will include both their work on
financial statements and that both the
money work so provide more information
hey put your apron 12 appendix turn a
pond 13 a fine 14
815 has an easy ride like to say the
last paragraph we are committed to
providing you in high quality service
anytime you bladder discuss with us our
service to you being pleased while
you're dissatisfied with service you
receive and please contact me um how do
we do are you saying please come with
Beth young we're not saying that this is
actually what Nui so 1415 will be the
the final year that video are your
external auditors and so the report that
we've just been through is out and you
plant the 14 15 and the work we're about
to do from a 415 technically but your 15
16 with it will be done by us than young
you what who are a different firm to us
so you would need to direct that
question to them all right then right
sorry you know sorry sorry entre video
so on the old yeah we're the outgoing
yeah this is good but we don't have
anybody to me more
but hopefully next time certainly
recommendation then is the quiz years
old to the external suspended for
2014-15 alone too yeah and digs that the
external that is planning letter 2015-16
be noted 9i 29 is the i propose audit
plan for the 2015-16 year it's a bit
later than we would normally like to
present this but obviously with changes
that we were ongoing and resourcing we
wanted to try and get some clear picture
of where we were going to be going for
the year but the draw members attention
to 3.1 in the covering report which is
on page nine point one as a basis for
the plan is that we want to ensure that
the core financial systems that weak
cylinders that all the financial ones
all the records and benefits are fully
covered that we would not decide
consider that an appropriate approach
would be not to change the way we do
things this year because of the redesign
and lots of people second again in
different structures we concentrate on
what we've done before they need to
maximize income due to the council to
review the management controls and risk
management in the reorganized structure
and tempt us a little bit the kink
engine see to allow for anything that
may crop up in our resources section 3.6
and page 9.2 we have now a member of
staff will be commencing on the
twenty-second of June to provide the
maternity cover for the year the person
in question he's very experienced in
business and he gives a financial
manager so he should have a very good
understanding of the the financial
aspects in things like creditors and
debtors so I think we all think you'd be
quite a useful member of staff appendix
1 is the planned
days for each all these assignments we
going to do this can I just question 3.6
but I don't know how members field but I
really don't think that final full time
Walter and a part-time ultra is
sufficient I think they're going to be I
think that there's got to be the
opportunities if anybody at once upon us
at risk it's going to be very difficult
for these that's one and a half members
to to look after the whole of the
council
for instance we've now got the part x
member of staff who is going on the
terms to leave if Jim does sub need to
be well taken sick or something like
that we'd be left with no auditors at
all we've got somebody as you say that
is about to start but he's got to be
trained I'm not happy about it I'd like
to hear what the rest of me
members feel about that in German I
think in our people hiding for fuels
were here last year pitching this was an
issue highlighted by the alki internal
walls to at the time concern was raised
as to where we would have the resources
to do the random spot checks the
in-depth
investigations that had highlighted a
number of issues hope it not major but
they hide like um quite early on before
they do become major i think it was it
was a concern though we all accepted at
that time and nothing really has
happened in the interview to make us
feel any better about the situation and
in fact we feel slightly more unsettled
because of the scenario that we now find
ourselves in as a as a chairman is just
a big reasons Rob's asking you the
question how you felt about it too but I
don't feel that we as a committee I mean
how that will service I tell everybody
in the idea were taking on the nose
numerous are simply because in my cost
of the price of it but a risk factor
because this dealing
we've got somebody that's true she was
saying south into a notorious yeah I'll
talking to me though I want to suggest
about whatever form and let Leslie came
up with look while that may be a member
of the star could shadow gym so they
have anything under scene happens which
we hope dozen at least and there's
somebody there that you could fall back
on dude also like so horrid also like to
and I had expressed this planned ordered
days it reduced 319 from 400mm something
from last year I would like to have that
comparison before I can make my decision
on this I would like to see that the
parison they plan to all your days to
decisions were last year to see where
our health gaps are because you know
400-500 reduce into 319 i think is quite
significant
twenty-five percent and that to me is an
extreme worry
if I don't sell yes I'll be just know
the details look this to last here but
about five or ten gets on top it's much
been to the Bahamas we use there are
pretty certain it was too
I most certainly was a cool mr. cell
think that's a separate issue I my
instincts our assistance
our other my situation since negative
music as the number of photons
yeah what we have done is I feel that we
should be able to cover the core of its
in the Decter we have done in the past
and provide the quiche assurances other
key financials what is the way I planned
to employ the temporary person coming in
was to be much more involved in the
day-to-day testing which would allow me
to do a little bit more overview the
high level stuff so it may not be a lot
bring so many August's into each audit
committee what would be working on them
through the year and summarizing them
and that's what a basis
relentlessly it's being penned a house
on that shiny use the resources we've
got but to make sure we cover the key
the key areas some of the nice to nice
to meet morbus we have not be able to do
and obviously they're still not those
sort of errors are not exception
potential issues so if he was suddenly
taken in order
then we can beat anybody yes
if we were looking at time our orbiting
staff am a risk assessment basis what
level of risk would we be putting into
either the Connecticut in that sort of
like a higher risk has read a lot we
would have lots of thing I've already to
be no sickness record but hopefully it's
on a low possible over low likelihood
but potentially high poverty hope
outcomes so the
no possibility based on your
if something did happen it would be a
major problem then that as it stands at
the moment there is no one with
experience within the castle in
determining which cuts make our homes
exactly what further is it come back to
risk knowing the implications of their
phone video we've got new external
auditor coming online we don't use our
expertise with that background knowledge
very few of you who fell by the wayside
would be in serious problems and I mean
the whole crux of this local authority
rests of audience is really any affects
everybody and I just think it's
something we can't overstuff so maybe we
could have a look at the number of days
that just
I don't think we can go back to many
years going to say in the two or three
years some people is done doing that for
yours well I expect we have but it's how
many reports which we throw to I love to
see one place finish what's up we sail
out the last five years then lost your
phone Israel there's a million last year
at my 45 years ago maybe one from ten
years ya doing that way so that's three
and you want to know and we're going to
know
it's just the number of auditing hours
and the number of auditing staff that we
had in those periods I was done Tommy
and I understand we've just got my son
Charlie agree with him because I think
the parameters of the job required has
changed substantially over the last few
years I don't disagree go back to a
three-year see what we've got but i
think is more critical is how we prepare
well what happened in the last two years
where we have highlighted a number a
little issues that came up again the
risk element of what we potentially have
now if you go see and the impact of
reducing this 400 days it's nice to say
well that we're nice to audit but they
look nice to audio because obviously
youthful they should be done you do it
just on a win some something maybe they
go you thought your group thought they
should be all set that's not going to
happen there well
okay ms Jamison does brief concern I
mean if you disappeared but these some
of these nice to audit things were nice
to all in and perhaps put the message
across that here we run the ball I don't
know but I can't quite agree going back
forever but the last few years I agree
particularly with what when in the last
two years I don't want that we achieve
it we you know we know what we've
highlighted in the last two years since
I've been on audio and and it's the
system has got tighter and tighter and
then only there's any dispute about that
but it's where we go from from here and
then risk because of their staff
scenario but that's not the Chairman I
to go more than two years because I'd
like to see the direction of change I
don't think they like 10 years is
realistic
but I think more than 24
five
well what I think is that difficult
dunno maybe but you want me said in the
first place with five years no sleep
ever trabuco provide five years when and
if every member of the audit Commission
could have a coffee
I don't deliver this is the right place
basket but we do talk about other
members of staff being able to fill in
these posts what I did mention trouble
yesterday that there is nobody at the
moment I understand and do that how
would we go about it as this audit
committee to request facebook chat to
have and I don't think it's just for
this department either i think with the
redesign of our council and reduction in
staff i think it would be quite
important to have other members of staff
who can fit into a particular area
if there is a riskier we not just talked
about you going to see if we're talking
about the star talking about a lot of
things in that in the hall of the
council how do we are we in a position
as the Audit Committee to request that
that is locked out chairman i think as
you are following the redesigning your
assistant directors have been looking at
various service of using have been
looking at their structures now it's not
something that the assistant directors
aren't aware of their have put forward
their staffing structures to your two
directors and to your chief exec already
now they and part of the exercise was to
look across division working and that
has been ducked out that's fine I mean
your concerns with regards I know I do
appreciate your concerns because there
was michael says well the fact that you
as a committee now have raised this with
my concerns well i can take that i can
certainly take that back to your
directors into your chief execs and but
it's not it's not really your remit to
make that decision i'm afraid but i
think it's something i will note and
take back to your party leadership see
if you would a new you obviously see
where we can get some as
yes absolutely any awesome Thank You mr.
issues arising as the redesign motion to
declare an interest of every year
it's not a lot and really actually where
we stand lately if suddenly we found
ourselves without rewarding me I think
the options are we don't know NC
externally for assistance I think we are
part of a criminal nutritive framework
where there is assistance out there it's
not ideal because you know they can eat
a bed in but there is a framework that
you can you see this was coming yeah
sure I know son was taken
we need this right come shalvoy not
succeed leader this is elijah concern to
the committee he's registered to no
[ __ ] just I wasn't there was an athlete
ok I'll sniper said easter is there any
benefit of them sending out and report
up to the executive to make them aware
of the concerns
to my content aware of the situation
she imagination in the executive plenty
not too sure how you would because the
executive are as far as I'm concerned
the presentations we made and staff
instructors are down to your directors
and the chief except the executive
itself doesn't have a say because your
head and paid service is yesterday so I
could raise that certain equal amount
ok
thank you thanks to the wonders of my
place and see this I look back do y'all
can ever have much but that I found
2009-2010 get 459 I leaders yeah 107 so
now that that's and that's about six
years ago so it's cup need a third age
last year it was that
I think it was fun that's what they
believe in magic light so we recovered
but of just going back from what you've
seen it really is like I was overeating
I'm a chip for waste management moments
etc many talking but it came very
obvious that we're going to have issues
when they start talking about new
contracts into a bear costing and so on
and I wasn't sure where this item there
because i was in again a bit concerned
because of the same issue of any
disability and I third of a meter what
you're going to be looking there on the
boise these if i don't know i think i
think is eliminating there at the moment
I think believe it with you thank you
yes yes now that you've got to directors
hear your concerns are noted we could
seriously take it back to your other
assistant directors and obviously to
your directors and achieve exact but is
not really a massively to decide and
stop in the
but yes certainly good we'll take it out
I'm doing a kind of diversion they're
not on our place to Haley all because I
chose me yeah yeah it all up yeah she's
very difficult to mountain yes we can
think you okay so everything covered on
that recommendation love it is proposed
that the committee resolves the 2015-16
all infant be agreed was there yes the
improviser so we sanitize shutter to the
caveat of if you get a chance to serve
okay
patience a subject to concern
sorry sorry I think of doing the farm
instructions that night for sure
never before you haven't don't take me
to any shouldn't be here so